president trump tells the general
services administration to begin the
transition process for joe biden biden
picks his cabinet and it's all dc
establishment insiders and democrats
push more coveted lockdowns but not for
themselves i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
in just one moment first
let's talk about how you can save a
bunch of money for yourselves it's not
even black friday yet but you can save
yourself hundreds of dollars a year how
well you can cut down on that cell phone
bill the reality is you are spending way
too much for your cell phone coverage
the reason is you are paying for
unlimited data you are not using
unlimited data the cell phone companies
know this they charge you for unlimited
data anyway
instead you should check out puretalk
usa puretalk is a veteran run wireless
company
think at t but much better if you're
with verizon at t mobile you're paying
way too much money pure and simple pure
talk can easily save you
over 400 bucks a year here's all you
need unlimited talk text and two gigs of
data for just 20 bucks a month
if you go over on data usage they don't
charge you for it switching to pure talk
is the easiest decision you will make
today you'll save yourself a bunch of
money and you have the same
great coverage that you get from the
other cell phone companies same towers
same sort of cell phone coverage grab
your mobile phone and i'll pound 250 say
ben
shapiro when you do you say 50 off your
first month dial pound 250. say keyword
ben shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
dial pound 250 say my name ben shapiro
and you say 50
off your first month and you're going to
be saving a bunch of money going forward
check out my friends at pure talk usa by
dialing pound 250
and saying my name ben shapiro okay so
late last night president trump tweeted
out
that he was going to allow emily murphy
who is the head of general services
administration
to move forward with the transition for
joe biden this doesn't mean he has
dropped his legal challenges
it does mean that he is not going to be
as i have suggested before
holding up in the oval office snorting
blow and firing machine guns through the
door
a la the the most fevered fantasies of
the members of the media this was always
a fantasy
members of the media were under the
grave misimpression that president trump
was going to
string barbed wire around the white
house and they were going to get the
glorious image
of people with uniforms and guns going
in and frog marching trump out of the
white house this was always wish
fulfillment by democrats
it was always fantasy by democrats and
president trump blew up that fantasy
last night when he said listen
you know my legal my legal challenges
are still ongoing here
but there will be an orderly transition
of power no matter what happens
he tweeted out i want to thank emily
murphy at gsa for her steadfast
dedication and loyalty to our country
she's been harassed threatened and
abused and i do not want to see this
happen to her family or employees of gsa
our case strongly continues we'll keep
up the good fight i believe we will
prevail nevertheless in the best
interest of our country i'm recommending
that emily and her team do what needs to
be done with regard to initial protocols
and have told
my team to do the same which of course
is the appropriate move
right he gets to move forward with all
of his legal challenges this thing
doesn't get voted on until december 14th
he gets to move forward and show
whatever evidence he has
in court the cases are not going well so
far but theoretically they could reverse
but in the meantime
he is not holding up the transition of
power that is supposed to happen
now the way the washington post suggests
is that emily murphy had done something
deeply wrong by not
starting the transition earlier the
problem of course is that none of the
states had certified their votes as of
last week now the states are starting to
certify their votes the electors don't
even meet
until the middle of december so she
really did not have any legal grounds to
do so
without the formal concession of the
president of the united states in the
race
right she is a person who holds a
government office and she is bound by
the law
and until the president concedes which
basically makes everything else a
formality she can't start the transition
trump giving her permission to start the
transition
allows the process to go forward the
washington post of course plays this as
though she had done something deeply
wrong by not unilaterally starting the
transition even though she really does
not have the power legally
to do so according to the washington
post
murphy a by the book expert in federal
procurement policy consulted with her
senior staff and her attorneys
the transition law dating to 1963 that
was supposed to guide her in determining
when a candidate had won had little to
offer in the current case with the
president refusing to concede in a
republican party
standing by him well no actually it's
just that the legal process
moving forward was just supposed to be
that the votes get certified and none of
the states had certified their votes yet
so again if trump had conceded then she
would have moved the transition forward
now he's given her permission
and so she's moving the transition
forward the media are trying to play
this as though trump was trying to stop
her from moving the transition forward
that's not right
he just was not giving her the
permission to move the transition
forward which was
necessary because she doesn't have any
other legal authority she does work for
the executive branch
she did write a letter to joe biden and
she said i've dedicated much of my adult
life to public service
i've always strived to do what is right
please know i came to my decision
independently based on the law and
available facts i was never directly or
indirectly pressured by any executive
branch official
including those who work at the white
house or gsa with regard to the
substance or timing of my decision to be
clear
i did not receive any direction to delay
my determination she said she received a
lot of threats
she said i always remain committed to
upholding the law
of course it is her job to make sure
that post-election resources and
services are available to assist in the
event of a
presidential transition but of course
the media declaring somebody
president-elect does not formally make
them by law
president-elect of the united states so
in any in any case
the the transition is beginning to move
forward in the meantime
president trump continues to move
forward with his legal challenges that
pathway continues to narrow last night
the michigan state board of canvassers
voted to certify the state's election at
results
that is a a board that is made up of two
republicans
and two democrats one of the two
republican members of the michigan state
canvassing board aaron van langeveld
joined the two democrats to vote to
certify the election results so
apparently it went
three to one the state's highly
anticipated certification was the latest
in a series of episodes over the past
week that have reinforced to biden's
victory even as trump has refused to
concede this is according to of course
cnn also in pennsylvania the state
supreme court
rejected the trump campaign's effort to
block the counting of certain absentee
ballots clearing the way for votes to be
certified in multiple counties including
philadelphia
uh the county of the county that
includes philadelphia did certify its
vote
last night and of course last week the
republican governor and secretary of
state in georgia certified the state's
election results although there will be
another recount that is going to happen
in georgia
as well the georgia secretary of state's
office according to daily wire announced
the additional recount on monday evening
during a press conference the trump
campaign criticized george's first
recount which took place over the course
of last week and uncovered two errors
worth thousands of votes each on
saturday the trump campaign is legally
entitled to a recount upon request with
the cost of such an operation covered by
georgia
state and local governments according to
politico the trump campaign is calling
for
some sort of re-examination of the
ballot based on the signatures on the
mail ballot envelopes that's gonna be
kind of difficult because originally
when you look at the mail ballot
envelopes the signatures are compared
and then the envelopes are thrown away
so it's not like that evidence
still exists at this point georgia's
going to end up certifying
the election meanwhile the trump
campaign
continues to try and move forward with
its own
legal theory rudy giuliani spelled out
that legal theory a little bit yesterday
we'll get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about great
watches so i'm a watch guy right i own a
bunch of
really luxury watches but luxury watches
cost a fortune they cost an
arm and a leg and you can get a great
watch at an affordable price
like a really nice looking durable
excellent
i mean these watches are great i'm
talking about ventura watches check this
one out
ventura they are dedicated to the craft
they put the time and effort into
crafting timepieces that you can wear
day after day head over to
venturawatches.com that is v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com
shapiro it makes a great gift for
hanukkah for christmas
avoid that rush of last-minute gifts and
shop their sale right now
i talk about the brand because i believe
in the products that they make i've been
wearing vincero watches when i'm with
my kids and i don't want to damage my
more expensive watches so instead i wear
this and they haven't damaged them
because they're incredible these watches
are just great
they run fantastically well they are as
i say very durable they look
great i mean this looks like a luxury
watch and it does not cost with a luxury
watch cost it's not gonna cost you
thousands
of dollars ventura offers free shipping
30 day returns guarantees your watch
for two years they believe in doing
things the right way so their customers
get the best and never have to settle
that's why they have twenty five
thousand five star
reviews you're not gonna get a watch
made it this well for this kind of price
anywhere else my listeners have been the
hero for vincero this year seriously the
folks of intro told me they are grateful
for support from ben shapiro show
listeners so please keep the emails
messages and letters going and keep
supporting
the businesses that support this show
head on over to venturawatches.com
shapiro for ventura's biggest sale of
the year that is v-i-n-c-e-r-o
venturawatches.com
shapiro go to my link and pick out your
favorite watch get a great discount
right now vincerowatches.com shapiro go
check them out
right now okay so rudy giuliani is uh
struggling to sort of explain the legal
strategy moving forward
so obviously the trump legal team dumped
sydney powell the other day because
sydney powell had been making wilder and
wilder accusations about the hacking of
voting machines and the suggestion
was that millions of votes were switched
trump had won 80 million votes not 73
million votes that the dominion voting
machines had actually been hacked
because smartmatic was originally a
venezuelan company
it was it was a bit of an extreme theory
and then she got even more extreme
suggesting that basically candidates
were paying dominion
in order to hack into the machines or
they'd been paid by dominion to allow
the hacking
of the machines and so just a couple of
days ago the trump campaign dumped
sydney powell on the side of the road
and they said we are no longer working
with her and then she said she's still
going to release a crack and this time
the kraken is going to be taking
steroids
as well as presumably some other form of
analgesic so that's exciting stuff
uh rudy giuliani was with lou dobbs
who's asked specifically why did you
dump sidney powell here was his answer
i think it's because we're pursuing two
different theories our
our theory of the case to get to the
supreme court now in four places and
it's
soon going to be in two others and
there'll be an overall lawsuit
is basically uh misconduct of the
election
by state officials in at least five or
six different states
in which the misconduct of the election
involves deprivation
of constitutional rights for the
president okay he then added
that they still have a legal strategy
that strategy is you know looking at the
various
voter regularities and voter fraud cases
uh the big problem again as it was in
pennsylvania is going to be proving that
the voter irregularities the voter
process the voter fraud cases that does
amount
to enough of a problem that state
election results as currently counted
should be overturned this was the
problem in pennsylvania or a couple of
affidavits
in which people said that their ballots
weren't properly counted the proper
remedy would be to have their ballots
counted
not to invalidate millions of votes this
is what the judge in that particular
case said they have the same problem in
michigan presumably they'll have the
same problem
in wisconsin arizona and nevada wherever
else they decide to file these lawsuits
you have to show that the voter fraud
and voter regularity the proper remedy
would be to set aside the election
result
and instead have the state lawmakers
select the electors to the electoral
college that is
the burden uh rudy is suggesting that
basically they are one good case away
from turning this whole thing around
the facts are there we just need to get
them uh before a try or a fact or before
a court that will be fair and we'll
listen to them i mean the court the
court in pennsylvania
cut it off without listening to a single
fact and i don't know how
how the judge could have concluded that
the facts aren't substantial
when they haven't even been presented
yet they're really kind of
and on a motion to dismiss you're not
supposed to consider that so
you're uh unfortunately we haven't yet
gotten
gotten a fair decision we will we got to
be a little patient
one fair decision one good hearing and
this will turn all around
okay so the legal process continues to
work this is why the
trump team has filed a lawsuit uh with
the third circuit court of appeals
asking for leave to amend their original
complaint
in that district court and then be
remanded back to district courts it's
going to go back down before it goes
back up
all of the states are going to certify
by december 8th so obviously the
timeline here
is quite short meanwhile there have been
calls from some people
like lynn wood in georgia for
republicans in georgia to somehow
boycott the georgia senatorial election
which is the dumbest thing i have ever
heard in my entire
life okay if you're a republican in
georgia and you are angry about
president trump's treatment and you
believe that president trump was somehow
job in georgia
okay i don't see how the solution is for
you to boycott an election
in which two democrats could be elected
john ossoff a radical progressive and
rafael warnock who's an actual nut
they could be elected and they could
theoretically give if
one of them if both of them were elected
democrats would then have a 50-50 split
in the senate of the united states and
if joe biden ends up taking office on
january 20th
which right now it appears he probably
will if that happens
then joe biden ends up presiding over a
a democrat-run senate with kamala harris
breaking the tie if you are a republican
in georgia get your ass out and vote
vote right now if you can vote right now
vote right now if you can vote mail-in
vote mail-in
if you can vote early vote early vote
right now do not
put like and you know who else is saying
this it's not just me donald trump jr is
saying this is nuts
now he's saying if you think that you're
helping my dad somehow by not voting in
the georgia senatorial elections
you're falling for a scam trump said i'm
seeing a lot of talk from people who are
supposed to be on our side telling gop
voters not to go out and vote for kelly
leffler and david perdue
this is nonsense ignore those people we
need all of our people coming out to
vote for kelly and david obviously that
is 100 true
so raphael warnock needs to lose jon
ossoff needs to lose
purdue narrowly missed being reelected
in the general election he did beat
ossoff by a couple of points
he got 49.8 percent of the votes he
needed 50 in order to prevent
the runoff on friday afternoon vice
president pence traveled to georgia to
campaign for leffler
and perdue he called purdue quote one of
the greatest and staunchest allies of
the
agenda in the u.s senate and praised
leffler for building her own company
from the ground
and breaking barriers in business and
sports okay the
the bottom line here is that republicans
cannot afford to have the democrats
running the senate
that's insane okay so regardless of what
you think happened in the presidential
election
please do not stay home out of s in some
sort of fit of peak
and hand the senate of the united states
to the democrats that is like the
dumbest thing
that you can do now the the dumbest take
from the media
this morning has come courtesy of of
friends on the
never trump left as well as the as well
as the actual
left these are people who have now
suggested that because
donald trump has allowed the gsa to move
forward with some of its transitional
processes
they stopped the coup so understand
these were people who were shouting from
the rooftops that a coup was in progress
that
america was in the midst of a
constitutional crisis it was all
grinding to a halt 200 and some odd
years of american history it was all
coming apart 250 years of american
history was all going to stop
because donald trump would refuse to
leave the office and we'd have a
constitutional crisis and then we'd have
to deploy
the the 101st airborne to the white
house in order to
reta it'll be white house down except
it'll be trump in the role of the
baddies okay that was always crazy talk
it was crazy talk from beginning to end
there are those of us
who are saying okay there's a process it
will play out either the evidence will
be presented or it will not be presented
but we do have a legal process and trump
has a right
to avail himself of all legal processes
but people on the left are saying no
it's the end of the republic it's a coup
it's the
as i said all along the reason they had
to keep saying this over and over and
over despite the fact that it was pretty
obvious there was a legal process
and that in fact it is not
unconstitutional nor is it illegal
for a president to avail himself of the
legal process in fact it's in the legal
proc like it's called the legal process
right
so that is not illegal you file a
lawsuit that is well within the legal
process
you don't have to concede that's a
formality and that is a nice city you
could theoretically run through
that's what trump is doing he's not
doing anything illegal and as i said all
along
the process will play out but the media
were fully invested in the line
that the entire republic was going to
come to a crushing halt because
president trump was such an evil bad man
the reason they had to say that is
because they have blown all of their
credibility for years
on the principle that donald trump is an
evil nefarious fascist democracy dies in
darkness
and so what would happen if donald trump
lost and then left
what would happen it would completely
undermine their narrative it would
undermine the excuse they've been using
for years to come out of the closet
as full-scale leftists while pretending
that they are still acting in objective
defense of the united states from this
incipient orange hitler
and so they had to continue maintaining
that myth it was it was necessary for
them to continue maintaining the myth
so how do they maintain the myth in the
in face of the fact that president trump
has now authorized the gsa to begin
transitional processes
in lieu of final legal outcome how do
they actually maintain the myth that
trump is a hitlerian fascist
who is going to seize power the reigns
of power uh you'll see it
is a pretty wild explanation and it's
and it's self-flattering of course we'll
get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about the
fact that um there's an object that you
carry around all day long it's extremely
dirty and then you put it
on your face you get it near your nose
you get it near your mouth
you never think about it it is your
phone of course right you take that
phone into the bathroom
with you and then five minutes later you
have the phone close to your face
right your phone is filled with germs
you got your hands all over it i know
all of this is making you feel a little
bit icky well this is why
you need phone soap you can clean your
phone with phones up the original
patented
clinically proven uvc phone sanitizer
they've been making phone sanitizers for
the last decade
phone soap uses uvc light and their
patented and clinically proven
technology to kill
99.99 of germs like e coli salmonella
and the cold and flu virus phone soap
can sanitize and charge your phone in as
little as five minutes
it's the only consumer uv sanitizer with
a 300 degree disinfectant
chamber it uses two transparent plates
to suspend your phone making sure all
sides are disinfected it's like a little
box you put the phone in there and now
it's being hit on all sides by the ufc
light and killing all the germs
phone soap makes many different models
for everyone the phone soap 3 sanitizes
in 10 minutes
the phone soap pro kills 99.99 of
bacteria in five minutes the home soap
is big enough to sanitize tablets
toys bottles and more so it's not just
for your phone it's pretty much
for everything that you need to maintain
a certain level of cleanliness from
today through cyber monday
go to phonesoap.com and use the code
santa 20 to save a whopping 20
off and receive free shipping phone soap
offers a lifetime
warranty on their bulbs as well from now
until cyber monday head on over to
phonessoap.com remember to use the code
santa 20
save 20 and free shipping that's phone
soap.com
remember use the code santa and the
number 20 to get that special
delivery at your door and the special
deal obviously 20
off okay so what is the case that uh
democrats are making
here because remember they still have to
maintain the myth members of the media
that trump is orange hitler who is about
to seize power
so this is my favorite jemele bowie who
is a
he's an idiot i mean there's another way
to put this the man he he is fully
committed
to a peculiarly radical style of
american politics in which all of his
opponents are badly motivated
um which is it's both morally corrupt
and idiotic in the extreme
anyway jamel bowie he he got angry
because
zaid jalani who is a commentator on
twitter
pointed out what was predicted mass
election violence chaos and the end of
democracy
what happened rage tweeting comical
lawsuits and an otherwise fairly robust
voter turnout
okay this happens to be basically the
case right yeah everyone was
saying this is the end of the republic
we were all going to die now we all know
what was going to happen in front one
right i mean if trump won they're going
to be riots in the streets there are
businesses boarding up in la dc new york
okay but then biden appeared to win and
suddenly everybody calmed down and so
they had to come up with a new crisis to
focus in on and the crisis was the
crisis of democracy okay so jemele bowie
responds to this obvious truth which is
that everybody was preemptively
panicking for no reason
by saying this the earnest attempt to
subvert and overturn the election didn't
pan out so the people who urged
vigilance were being hysterical
is the pr is probably going to be
conventional wisdom for the professional
contrarian set
well um hold up um
well no you you were being hysterical so
instead i guess the argument
is that according to jamal bully the
coup was going to happen except that
jamel bowie tweeted about it and then
didn't happen
which is really exciting news is that
people on twitter tweeting about things
it makes
change happen it's very flattering to
the to the commentary set to believe
that if you tweet loudly enough about
things
they magically occur so the cool was
about to happen but then
jamel bowie tweeted and wrote in the new
york times about how the cool was about
to happen and then trump uncooed
or alternatively you guys are radical
morons hey david frum another radical
and not radical in politics just radical
in his stupidity at this point he
tweeted out perhaps
some excited person did overreact to
something that happens but if you're one
of those belittling what the country
just went through the people who worried
they saved your country
without you nope
nope okay the people who worried did not
save the country the people who worry
just made things worse on twitter which
is what they do all day
david frum didn't save the country by
sitting there and fretting this basic
notion in politics that if you worry
really deeply about a thing
that you are helping is really stupid
it's not true it's not true in any walk
of life
worry rarely solves problems you know
action solves problems but
it wasn't even though as though popular
action solved the problem there was no
elected official anywhere here
who was pressured by the constituents
into doing something different
you know what was always going to happen
the legal process you know what happened
the legal process
federal judges struck down lawsuits that
they didn't think had an evidence cherry
basis
you saw republicans saying that votes
were going to be certified and the votes
were certified
so wasn't david frum and his cadre of
malcontents
sitting there and rage tweeting through
the night about how this was a
an assault on democracy and it was the
end of everything and this was going to
be like pinochet taking power
okay all of that was crap and you guys
got humiliated because it was crap and
now you're insisting that the only
reason it didn't happen is because
you're rage tweeting about it i'm sorry
you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous like you know who
points this out is ben dreyfus the
editorial director of mother jones he
gets this right he tweeted out
the idea that people who predicted the
very worst outcomes are actually just
vigilant is insane
in the days before the election i had
multiple people tell me biden would win
but that would be stolen
that our militias would kill thousands
of people in the streets
he's at no point since november 4th has
it ever been in doubt that biden would
be inaugurated on january 20th
literally for months before the election
media made it seem that actual revolut
actual revolutions in bleep were
possible
he says that there's a radio lab from
right before the election which you can
dig up yourself where they say it might
come down to who the military thinks
should get the nuclear codes
like what the f game of pretend is this
people believe this bleep because media
places say it
he says one man's paranoid
catastrophizer is another man's just
being vigilant this is exactly right
okay if ben dreyfus from mother jones
can see it why can't folks on the
mainstream left see it because
folks on the mainstream left or
anti-trump forces on the right had a
picture of trump that picture
has been cracked at every available
opportunity by the actual action of
trump now by the stuff he says trump
always says ridiculous stuff but the
stuff he actually does
trump was never at any point going to
seize power in a coup requiring the
military to kick him out that was always
something that the left wanted to see
because it would have fulfilled their
picture of who trump was and who trump's
supporters are by extension
because see you see for the left they
they have not been doing particularly
well in these elections
joe biden won he only won because the
media spent four years
basically consigning trump to the bowels
of hell while ignoring joe biden's
actual record on every available issue
and the median lying about every
available narrative and trump shooting
himself in the foot a lot
okay but in congress they didn't do well
in the senate they didn't do well and so
they have to come up with an excuse and
the excuse for democrats
is always the same the american people
are dullards they are dullards
they are dullards or they are racist or
they are bigots and that's why they
follow
president trump and that is always the
narrative that's the narrative from the
media
even today right they continue to push
forward this narrative
now this is sunny hostin on the view
suggesting that republicans voted for
trump knowing he was racist this all
ties together
if you paint trump as the world's
deepest threat that means that you also
get to paint his voters as the world's
deepest threat
and you get to paint half the country as
terrible terrible people which of course
makes leftists feel better
about not being able to win over those
people you hear sonny hostin saying this
i think trumpism is here to stay quite
frankly like you said um
whoopi enjoyed 70 over 70 million people
voted for him
uh in spite of the fact that they knew
that he was racist and misogynist
uh transphobic homophobic
um and so they voted for him anyway um
and it just
it just seems to me that that uh
people's hearts and minds don't change
that quickly
and if we stop talking about uh
president trump
then you know i i'm always fearful that
past becomes prologue right
ah if we so they're just going to
continue talking about president trump
because of course it allows them a
prison to castigate all of trump's
supporters
as ignorant bigots and that's really the
end goal here isn't it the longer he can
portray trump as a dictator even though
he started the process of transition
with the gsa
without having conceded the election
even the longer you can continue to
portray everybody who disagrees with you
as a morally benign fool
really solid stuff here from the media
and from the left we'll get some more of
that in just one second because this is
sort of media conventional wisdom first
let's talk about your safety and your
security
and keeping an eye on your property so
for me i got three kids under the age of
seven
and they're kids that means that i
really need to keep an eye on them
because sometimes they do things that
are not particularly smart and i want to
be able to run in and stop them from
doing it but there's only one of me and
there are three of them they are as i
like to call them the army of the
children
and this is why i love my ring device i
can keep an eye on them anywhere
anytime and keep an eye on them
simultaneously it's fantastic with ring
you can keep an eye on all the hustle
and bustle
in your house at your front door no
matter where you are right from your
phone if somebody stops by or something
is going on ring lets you know you can
see and speak to whoever is there from
anywhere
this holiday season it's not just the
best time to have ring it is the best
time to give it as well
ring makes a great holiday gift this
holiday season gives someone the gift
of peace of mind ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside now best of all you can see it
all in
the ring app ring has everything you
need to keep an eye on home this holiday
season and
throughout the year help protect your
whole home with ring alarm it's a
powerful affordable whole home security
system
you can easily install yourself now as a
public figure i'm deeply concerned about
my own safety which is why as soon as we
moved my wife insisted we put up the
ring devices
you should too for a limited time go to
ring.com ben
receive special black friday and cyber
monday offers that is ring.com
go check them out right now ring.com ben
okay so
the entire media has jumped into this
narrative that even though trump
has started the sort of transitional
process and this means
that uh he was going to be a dictator
and you should never work with
republicans because republicans are bad
don lemon on cnn a very objective
journalist starts journalism everywhere
the journalism was getting
pretty much all over the place here here
he was with block of wood chris cuomo
explaining there should never be any
unity with republicans because
republicans are bad because they were
going to be
complicit in a coup that never happened
and was never going to happen
how do you come to some sort of
compromise or an agreement
with a person who doesn't believe in
science person who doesn't believe in
facts person who doesn't believe in
reality how do you come to some sort of
agreement
that you don't care enough about maybe
yourself
or you don't care enough about someone
else that you just can't put a little
piece of cloth over your face i don't
know where
the compromise and the come togethering
another center
where that's going to come from you
can't compromise with these people you
can't come together with them they
support coups they won't put out a mask
again the idea here from the media is
that everybody who disagrees with them
is morally bad
is morally bankrupt and the way you can
tell this is because trump is morally
bad
and morally bankrupt as trump said and
it was the truest thing that he said in
all of his years in politics they don't
hate him
they don't hate you because they hate
trump if you support trump they don't
hate you because they hate trump
they hate trump because they hate you
he's just a stand-in for their hatred of
you because you think
differently meanwhile joe biden has
started selecting his cabinet
and it's amazing to watch how the media
in real time switch from
donald trump is awful and he's a swamp
creature and he's corrupt
and he's compromised to you know it'd be
great again like the old washington
parties with the schmoozing and
everything
because basically joe biden is just the
swamp and we've known this for a very
long time he's a conventional politician
going back
50 years he is a swamp thing he occupies
the swamp
and the media are celebrating this stuff
because the media went from democracy
dies in darkness to
you know what if we don't watch so
closely anymore that's okay because you
know this is just the establishment
doing what the establishment does
the washington post originally had a
headline titled washington's aristocracy
hopes a biden presidency will make
schmoozing
great again they changed that to
washington's establishment because they
realized
that it sounded kind of bad this is from
the washington post lifestyle section
roxanne roberts writes washington is
exhausted washington is optimistic
washington is desperate for change the
aristocracy of the city is ready to move
on
during to hope that the last four years
was a fever that finally broke and life
can get back to normal now a lot of us
are thinking to ourselves
back to normal means the same cast of
liars
who occupied high positions of power and
in a flowered and honeyed
language spoke soft promises into our
ears that were never fulfilled
sold out the interests of the united
states to powers adverse to the
interests of the united states
and got rich in the process right that's
what washington dc was
before trump got there trump didn't fix
all of those problems but he did blow up
a lot of the conventional wisdom
that dominated particularly in the
foreign policy circles of washington dc
and that was quite good because it ended
with china feeling more confronted than
ever
it ended with iran feeling boxed in well
now the washington dc establishment is
happy because they're back on top and
guess what the media is part of that
washington dc establishment
your legacy media are part of the system
they are not sitting apart from the
system and keeping an eye on the system
they are not keeping an eagle eye on
action you you want to know how
non-objective the media
are all you have to do is not just look
at their treatment of the trump
administration
in a vacuum right because that's what an
adversarial media looks like it's the
fact that they stopped being adversarial
the media
the the minute their friends are in
power so you get this from the
washington post
normal they're looking back to life
getting back to normal the aristocracy
of the city normal as in respect for
experience and expertise
normal as incivility and bipartisan
cooperation normal as in not wanting to
punch someone
in the face at the center of this hope
is president-elect biden moderate by
nature attuned to the rhythms of the
town
eager to bring people back together
spare me okay i'm just gonna vomit until
there's no more places to vomit in the
studio it's gonna be like the exorcist
let me explain experience and expertise
as we'll explore
with the with the biden cabinet and the
supposed biden administration
experience and expertise means a bunch
of washington dc insiders who have been
wrong on every major issue of the last
three decades
civility and bipartisan cooperation
means castigating all of your opponents
races up to including mitt romney
their new best friend mitt romney joe
biden was saying that he wanted to
re-enslave black people
just eight years ago as for as far as
not wanting to punch somebody in the
face
you may have noticed that the people who
are largely doing the punching in the
face are the people who say it's time to
punch nazis and then declare that all
trump supporters are nazis
but it's back to normal guys and the
media have decided that it's time to
stop
it's time to stop worrying and be happy
and love the swamp
according to the washington post at the
heart of this optimism is the belief
that politicians on both sides of the
aisle get more accomplished when they
like each other and the other business
of washington
the cultural institutions the diplomatic
core the gala fundraisers the hundreds
of historical traditions need
bipartisanship to really thrive
they struggled during the trump
administration when everything became a
test of loyalty and the notion that good
people could disagree without being
disagreeable was laughable again
donald trump did not create those
conditions in washington d.c
donald trump was the coroner of american
politics he was not the murderer
bipartisanship died during the obama era
george w bush pursued no child left
behind he pursued medicare part d
george w bush actually did pursue
bipartisan cooperation and then the
democrats spat in his face from 2006 on
and suggested that he was evil nefarious
bush hitler who wanted to destroy the
economy
and murder iraqis and then
obama came in and proceeded to never do
a single piece of serious bipartisan
legislation not one you cannot name a
serious piece of bipartisan legislation
that barack obama did the only thing you
can name that he did with republicans
was sequestration which ended with the
gutting of the american military
that is the only major thing that trump
that obama ever did
and he spent his entire career
castigating the other side as covert
racist
if you read his stupid autobiography his
latest one million page tone about how
wonderful he is and how disappointed he
is in you
and the rest of america the entire book
is about how everybody who opposed him
is either stupid or racist or both right
the tea party was just a bunch of
racists
and yet we're being told by washington
we're gonna go back to that normal that
normal is the time when you all got
along don't you know
that normal was a time when
bipartisanship thrived if you can
explain to me how bipartisanship thrived
when barack obama literally declared he
couldn't get out anything done so he's
gonna use a pen and a phone to overwrite
his constitutional powers
more power to you because it doesn't
make any sense it is just you being lied
to
it's just being it's you being lied to
they say that they're going to bring
back the white house correspondents
dinner oh happy clapping the white house
correspondents dinner is going to come
back
yay typically a night of mutual good
will between the administration and the
press that covers it
became an awkward defense of the first
amendment sometimes tense when comedian
michelle wolf eviscerated sarah sanders
well
i mean actually she called her ugly
sometimes lackluster when ron chernow
was recruited to speak the following
year
oh you mean the white house
correspondents center that spent its
time making jokes about how wonderful
obama was and how terrible
bush was oh yeah that back to normal it
means more state dinners
a prestigious glamorous way of
re-establishing global ties oh you mean
the aristocrats are back and they get to
have black thai dinners with
foreign dignitaries well people in the
united states can't go back to work
because democrats are locking down their
cities
good times really exciting it also means
that washington events traditionally
attended by the president and first lady
the honors the alfalfa dinner the
gridiron ford theater's gala the
correspondent center will likely return
to their former glory
oh how nice aren't you excited we're
going back to normal guys
and normal is going to be so awesome
because it sucked so much the first time
that we elected trump
this is how you got trump and the
media's take away from this is let's
just go right back to it
it was great the obama era was wonderful
we'll get some more of this because this
is how biden is staffing his cabinet
as well if you thought that the old
normal was great then i'm sure you will
enjoy
a joe biden administration if you
thought the old normal sucked get ready
for more of it because here it comes
down the pike the fully corrupt
fully establishment bad conventional
wisdom hang out with all of your
bipartisan cronies
in pursuing bigger government and
violating the rights of individual
americans
that's exciting stuff because the really
important thing is that we have the
veneer of nicety
atop the roiling the roiling chaos of
american politics
not that we'd be honest about our actual
divisions in the country we can never be
honest about our actual divisions
instead we'll go back to a time when the
president of the united states
subtly suggested that everybody who
opposed his big government agenda was a
sick
a sick bastard and but that'll be good
because i mean then it'll be
you know back to nicely i mean then
you'll have like joe biden who speaks
with like
a bit more flowery tone then at least
you won't have the tweets i mean at
least you won't have the tweets we'll
get to more of this in just
one second first let's talk about your
sleep quality if all of this makes you
want to lose sleep you still need your
sleep and that's why you need a mattress
that is personalized
for you i have one it's helix sleep i
don't just have one because i'm special
i have one because helix sleep will do
this for everyone
right they have a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete they match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep everybody
is unique helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models
to help you choose they have soft medium
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down
if you sleep hot even a helix sleep
mattress for plus size folks
i took the helix cl the helix sleep quiz
and i got a firm mattress that really
breathes really well because i tend to
heat up a lot
when i sleep and it is absolutely
comfortable it is awesome
checking out helix sleep go check them
out right now a lot of folks have been
sending us unboxing videos
you also found the helix fleet mattress
of your dreams if you are looking for a
mattress take the quiz or the mattress
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store again it gets shipped directly to
your door for free
right now they've got a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free so you really have nothing to
lose head on over to helix sleep.com
ben take their two minutes leave quiz
they will match you to that customized
mattress again that's helixsleep.com
check them out right now hey so it's not
just
that we are going to reestablish all of
the wonderful swampy traditions that
existed before
biden's cabinet is going to be full of
swampy people cnn is particularly pumped
about this
so it's hilarious donald trump appointed
a gay ambassador
to to germany richard grinnell he
appointed a black secretary of housing
and urban development in
ben carson donald trump
had a wide variety of of people
including the first
uh successful female campaign manager
and kellyanne conway none of that was
historic
right it's only historic when a democrat
does things so biden's cabinet his
cabinet picks are all dc establishment
insiders who are mostly white
they're mostly white men cnn declares
this is very historic it's like john
kerry is coming back that's historic i
mean historic in the sense that john
kerry never left and he has always been
around
and captain easter island head over here
he's he's coming back are you excited
about that cnn says
it's so historic so much history making
in the cav
it's so tiresome it's so tiresome to go
from donald trump is the font of all
evil to all the people who sucked at
politics for decades on end i mean john
kerry
has not just been wrong on every major
political decision of his entire career
he also happens to be
going all the way back to his lying
testimony during the vietnam war a very
not good person
john kerry is a historic figure
according to cnn
if you trust cnn honestly i have a
bridge in brooklyn to sell you
and if you don't trust cnn cut your damn
cable and get daily wire or go get the
blaze or go get
or go get a subscription to some other
news service because i mean these people
are just awful
a historic first at the department of
homeland security
president-elect biden is saying he will
indeed nominate
alejandra mahorcas he'll be the first
immigrant and latino
if confirmed to serve as the the head of
dhs
as well as the director of national
intelligence another historic
pick there of real haines biden has
whittled down the list
to former fed chair janet yellen or
current
federal reserve governor lail brainard
now both of these women would make a
historic appointment the first
woman treasury secretary okay so um
just just gonna point out here that um
there have been
hispanic people who have served in high
positions in the trump administration
and and by the way painting janet yellen
is historic is absurd
i mean janet yellen headed the federal
reserve for years and years and years
okay is she significantly more powerful
if we have points for the head of the
treasury department like
this it's all ridiculous it's all the
media trying to spin biden's victory
into something transformational when
really it's just a return to the bad old
days that's all it is
and let's face it the bad old days they
weren't that great we're being told the
great old days of obama it was an era
bipartisanship and warmth
no it was an era of bipartisanship if by
bipartisanship you mean the media got
along famously with the folks in the
white house who are simultaneously
threatening them
if that's what you mean by
bipartisanship then yay good for you
guys you can be all happy again
it's your happy time i mean you won't
have donald trump to beat up on so your
ratings are going to decline markedly
but still
you'll have your happy day your happy
day where you can just go and hang out
with joe biden and ask him softball
questions and he can mumble his way
through an answer that doesn't make any
sense and start talking about corn pop
and then you can have yourself a great
great time so who exactly is on biden's
team
who is this transformational team this
historic historic team
well according to politico it's a team
of careerists oh yeah you mean all the
old people
all the people who they had like five
minutes ago the most prominent
appointment president-elect joe biden
according to political has made for his
new white house team
is chief of staff ron clayne a longtime
biden advisor who went to harvard law
school and won a prestigious supreme
court clerkship
the most prominent appointment he has
made so far to his cabinet is secretary
of state designate anthony blinken a
longtime biden advisor who went to
harvard as an undergrad and then moved
through the washington foreign policy
establishment
how about jake sullivan the choice to
lead the national security council a
previous biden advisor who went to yale
and then there's bruce reed who's been
talked about he's a veteran biden aide
his choice for treasury secretary janet
yellen
is not a longtime biden advisor but she
served as head of the federal reserve
throughout the entirety of the obama
administration
so basically he's bringing back all of
these people and people oh wow it's
transformational isn't it
because your media lied to you they are
damned liars and all they do
all day long is talk about how
everything is swampy when trump is
running the place but then the actual
swamp
rushes back in with all the attendant
muck and they're like oh it's
transformational and it's also a return
to normalcy
amazing amazing okay so let's go through
some of the people that
that biden has now selected for his
cabinet
so some of the people that biden has
selected for his cabinet it is
basically the same old faces who blew it
the first time around
who sucked at their jobs the first time
around okay anthony blinken he's better
than susan rice
because a bag of flaming hot dog crap is
better than susan rice would be as
secretary of state i mean susan rice
lied repeatedly to the american people
about benghazi
chapman radically anti-israel she's been
wrong on every major foreign policy
issue and she has scorned for half the
american population
anthony blinken isn't that but that's
kind of what you can say about anthony
blinken i mean that's kind of like the
whole thing
so anthony blinken has been wrong about
a wide variety of issues he was wrong on
iran for example
this is all the conventional wisdom just
returning it's all just the conventional
like
he's a very articulate guy anthony
blinken he served
again in the uh he served again in the
obama administration
and with joe biden in the senate and
everything that he has said is
conventional wisdom nonsense it's just
not true
see the thing about the trump
administration is the one area where
they were actually the best is in
foreign policy they didn't start any new
wars
they boxed iran in they helped form
actual middle eastern peace deals
they helped so they they helped box
china in right
they they did a bunch of things on
foreign policy that were actually quite
good but the conventional important
foreign policy wisdom is going to rush
back in because
no need to actually examine the new
evidence they had to be right all along
and we know they're all right all along
because they are the conventional wisdom
i mean they wouldn't be called the
conventional wisdom if they weren't wise
right
i mean anthony blinken in 2012 spoke at
the j street conference j
street is a radically anti-israel group
posing as a pro-israel group
simply so that democrats can pretend
they're pro-israel by speaking to j
street which again has opposed
every element of israeli security since
its inception it was specifically
created as a counter to aipac
because the democrats thought that aipac
was too pro-israel so they had to create
this bull crap group
of people who really don't like israel
very much so blinken spoke to them and
he suggested
that israelis and palestinians could
only make peace if they actually started
making peace agreements between
themselves the arabs would never make
peace without the
without the israelis making peace with
the palestinians that of course was
absolutely false
it was also conventional wisdom it was
blinking in 2017 was still maintaining
the iran deal was absolutely fantastic
even though iran has spent the better
part of all of its time since the iran
deal
fostering terrorism and it was only the
renewed sanctions against iran that
undercut its economy
and helped create the impetus for an
alliance in the middle east between arab
states and
israel including saudi arabia benjamin
netanyahu who went and visited saudi
arabia yesterday here's anthony blinken
being
absolutely wrong about the iran deal if
you ask
the israeli military or intelligence
community today
whether we should pull out of the deal
you will get a resounding
no and in fact many of them have
acknowledged to us some will actually
say this publicly others won't
that it has removed a significant
concern for them at least
far into the future everything we've
seen in our intelligence community has
seen
and said publicly is that the
overwhelming bulk of the proceeds that
they've managed to get back
have gone into the economy not not to
hesitate i mean this is insane okay he's
just saying absolute crap and this guy's
gonna be secretary of state the israelis
hated the iran deal they hate it
benjamin netanyahu came to the united
states to lobby against the iran deal
and obama showed him the back door of
the white house so that guy who's
complicit in that entire process
he's like oh i'm back and i'm here with
my conventional wisdom that was
completely debunked by subsequent
defense but don't worry i haven't
changed my opinions
at all by the way i love how he's like
well you know most of that money went
back to the economy not to terrorism
most of the money how about the billions
that did not go back into the economy
but instead were used to foster regional
terrorism apparently that doesn't matter
okay he's not the only one in the in the
new biden cabinet who is who's pushing
failed conventional wisdom particularly
on iran we'll get to more of this in
just
one second first let us talk about some
bad news so business owners i have some
bad news for you if you are not using
text messages you are really really
missing out many of you are not using
text messages you're trying to call
people and they're not calling you back
you're sending them an email it's going
directly to their spam folder you need
to be using
text okay you text your friends but if
you are a business and you're not using
text you're missing out
you can save time and money you're not
going to spend as much effort calling
customers about their order or their
appointment texts get open 97 of the
time your customers will get their
message you can text back and forth
giving you freedom from being tethered
to your phone how can you make your
business text friendly you can check out
podium
podium works fantastically fantastically
well podium helps you transition over
to a text-based business and right now
i'm teaming up with podium
for a special offer for a limited time
you can sign up with podium for 20
off your plan they're so confident that
if podium doesn't make your business
better within 90 days they'll send you a
amazon gift card for the holidays go to
podium.com shapiro
to get started that is 20 off if you go
to p-o-d-i-u-m.com slash apparel go to
podium.com
shapiro today to get started we're
talking about car dealers who've been
selling cars only through text and
dentists booking appointments before the
end of the year using
just text you can be doing that kind of
stuff make your business more efficient
check them out podium.com
shapiro and get 20 off if you use that
special code podium.com
shapiro okay we'll get back to the
reestablishment of the establishment
celebrated by the media right your media
democracy dies in darkness media
first thanksgiving is almost here that
means black friday is almost here as
well since last year's black friday deal
we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program
we are super excited about what is yet
to come there is a lot yet to come to
name a few things
we've added more exclusive readers past
content our insider and above members
can now stream our content on apple tv
and roku we are currently adding the
entire prageru catalog
behind our paywall your account now
comes with custom badges that you can
earn by participating in current events
as well if you're an all access member
you get to join all access live that's
our exclusive daily live streams with me
or one of the other hosts where we talk
directly with you about well
pretty much anything gave a lot of
parental advice last night on all access
live some
spousal advice also i sang bizarre songs
and did weird impressions you also get
two leftist years tumblers
early access to our daily wire merch and
daily discussions with our writers and
special guests as well
we're also continuing to add new
features and products like the entire
prageru library that is currently being
added to the website and
content from candace owens who's joining
us next year with a brand new show
needless to say we are pretty excited
about this year's deal you will not want
to miss it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the establishment is back in
with its conventional wisdom like iran
is great and the iran deal is great and
the israelis will never be able to make
peace
with the arab states without the
palestinians being involved all of it
was wrong all that was wrong you also
had tony blinken
circa 2017 talking at goldman sachs
which shows you how establishment
insidery the entire biden team is
saying we should have done more
militarily in syria yeah that would have
been a great idea is to dump more
american troops into syria
those of us involved in the diplomacy at
various points thought that it might
make a difference
if uh we showed a little bit of muscle
as a way of leveraging the diplomacy and
there are various things that we thought
about
that i couldn't tell you today whether
they in fact would have made a
difference
but at the time we thought they would be
worth trying
the military was very concerned
understandably about getting into a
slippery slope okay just a quick point
here
donald trump was decried by the leftist
warmonger he didn't start a new war
because tony blinken says things like
leverage and we're going to leverage
diplomacy using other assets which is
code for we're going to bomb places and
kill people
and we're supposed to believe that he's
actually like a nice guy because
democrats are nice people while they're
droning people and bombing places and
launching unconstitutional wars in libya
and so that's exciting we've got that
whole team coming up by the way obama
has already
said that he's very excited about this
new team you know who's back also is
john kerry
drawn car i mean i'm excited because i
get to do my john kerry impersonation
again so that's good i thought that that
sucker was going to die in 2004
and that's been around a subsequent 16
years so john
carlsbach he's back and he's worse than
ever
he's going to be the new climate zorro
which is exciting it means he gets to
stay at uh as john tom cotton says he
gets to stay
at wonderful luxury hotels while
negotiating deals that are bad for
america that's
accurate john kerry was the architect of
the crappy iran deal he then proceeded
to become a pr flak for the
nation of iran and more importantly for
the mullahs that rule iran suggesting
that their pursuit of terrorism in the
region was really
no big deal john kerry wrong about every
major issue of his entire lifetime
here was john kerry suggesting just a
few years ago that peace in the middle
east would literally be impossible if
israel did not make concessions to the
palestinians here he was being as wrong
as a human being can be but don't worry
the good news is that if you are a
member of the government you always just
keep failing up
if you suck at something you will end up
as president one day because you will
just keep failing up joe biden is proof
of this here is here is john kerry who
nearly became president
narrowly we nearly avoided that here he
was being totally wrong about everything
good news he's got a new slot where he
gets to talk about climate change
presumably
making the american economy worse to no
apparent effect
there will be no separate peace between
israel and the arab world
i want to make that very clear to all of
you i've heard
several prominent politicians in israel
sometimes saying
well the arab world is in a different
place now we just have to reach out to
them and
we can work some things with the arab
world and we'll deal with the
palestinians no
no no and no there will be no
advance and separate peace with the arab
world
without the palestinian process and
palestinian peace
everybody needs to understand that
everybody needs help and i know what i'm
talking about because i'm wearing
my glasses very far down on my nose
which means i know what i'm saying
that guy is a he is the stupidest
person in american foreign policy and
he's going to be in charge
of america's climate change policy which
already is rife with stupidity and a
complete disconnect between actual
meaningful action on climate change
and what democrats are talking about
paris agreements don't do a
they don't do a bleep's worth okay they
are not worth anything the paris
agreements are worthless their accounts
are productive
i've talked at length about actual
things you could do in order to fight
climate change it could do adaptation
you could be building infrastructure you
could be
investing in technologies that help suck
the carbon out it's all sorts of stuff
you can do but you put that
in charge that's good news also
president biden is bringing
president-elect biden as they are now
designating him he's not formally
president-elect yet
he plans to nominate janet yellen former
federal reserve chairman she's
transformational too
except for the fact that she was the
federal reserve chairwoman for years and
years and years and years her basic
philosophy
is that you keep pumping money into the
economy until
you get unemployment down she's also
not super warm on capitalism here is
what she said recently there really is a
new kind of recognition
you've got a society where capitalism is
beginning to run amok and needs to be
readjusted in order to make sure that
what we're doing is sustainable
and the benefits of growth are widely
shared in ways they haven't been oh
goody so we can use monetary policy in
order to achieve political goals
democrats couldn't otherwise
achieve okay and it doesn't the cabinet
doesn't stop there
are you guys ready for more excellent
stuff alejandro mallorca
a former deputy homeland security
secretary is now going to lead the
homeland security department
now that's not really a particularly big
deal he would take the lead on enforcing
immigration and border law also
providing a coordinated response to
terrorism maritime aviation
and cyber security threats he's supposed
to be a stabilizing force
inside the biden administration there's
only one problem which is that he has
faced barriers in a path to confirmation
before
after he was nominated to serve as
deputy homeland security secretary the
department's inspector general
investigated him
for intervening to help expedite visa
reviews for foreign investors
while leading the us citizenship and
immigration services he was found not to
have broken the law
but the inspector general released a
report in 2015 that found he managed
cases for eb-5 visas in a way that led
employees to believe he was giving
special consideration to
investors aligned with democrats ah the
swamp is back and better than ever how
exciting
okay so the establishment is back that
is the bottom line here
and uh it's ugly it's ugly i mean jake
sullivan is back
and jake sullivan again a uh a former
deputy nsa guy under barack obama and he
was a hillary clinton acolyte
he helped run her campaign and here he
was suggesting that trump created the
iranian crisis
and uh that that iran was so much better
before
before donald trump got involved which
neglects the fact that iran was killing
american soldiers in the field
while barack obama was president of the
united states here's jake sullivan
sucking at his job but don't worry he's
back too
we are in the midst of a crisis with
iran today because donald trump decided
to tear up the iran nuclear deal to walk
away from the agreement now he went out
and said it's because of the deal that
we're in this crisis when in fact it's
exactly the opposite
donald trump has spent the last three
years trashing
our nato allies telling the rest of the
world that they can basically
go take a hike and now those very same
allies and partners
are putting out statements where they're
calling on both iran and the united
states to de-escalate where they're
saying a pox on both your houses
where they're basically putting iran and
the united states on the same plane
okay so are you dude okay again this is
the the new biden cabinet same as the
old biden cabinet
i hope that you've enjoyed this i hope
you enjoyed that four year interregnum
between the continuing rule of the
american aristocracy of wrongness
between new secretary of state tony
blinken
who again has been wrong on every major
issue push the iran deal
push softness on china between john
kerry who is back and worse than ever
he's going to be heading up the climate
change nonsense
you got janet yellen for treasury
secretary who uh
has been suggesting that the federal
reserve should be buying long-term bonds
and more
mortgage-backed securities to prop up
the market and has suggested her
antipathy to certain elements of what
she calls kind of dog-eat-dog
capitalism you've got alejandro mayarcas
for the department of homeland security
who of course was investigated for the
possibility of engaging in
eb-5 immigration form fraud in order to
benefit democratic donors
it turned out that he did not violate
the law according to the investigation
but he did provide the appearance of
violating lola you got jake sullivan
for nsa former hillary clinton guy
that's exciting and
just to spice things up just to spice
things up a little bit joe biden is also
adding a person named rima doden
as well as schwann zaghoff they were
each named deputy director of the office
of legislative affairs
dodin currently serves as deputy chief
of staff and floor director for senator
dick durbin the assistant minority
leader
so she's historic because she was born
to arab israeli immigrants
in north carolina she's also historic
because she is
incredibly radical it turns out that in
she justified suicide bombings as quote
the last resort of a desperate people
talking about palestinian suicide
bombings this is according to israel 365
news
one year earlier she took part in a
demonstration at uc berkeley calling for
the university to divest
from israel according to the berkeley
daily planet at that demonstration
protesters compared israel to apartheid
south africa
she's in regular contact with the
radical council on american islamic
relations
so that is exciting stuff really really
good stuff
meanwhile by the way the radicals in the
democratic party are displeased because
there are so many establishment members
of the democratic party so the battle
has just begun
over there the radicals in the
democratic party are very upset because
they wanted more radicals so rashida
talib who ain't a friend of the jews you
may have noticed
she tweeted out that she was deeply
deeply unhappy
why because tony blinken might be too
pro-israel which is absurd okay tony
blinken
is not an extremely pro-israel guy he is
like mainstream democratic party which
means ambivalent about israel
at this point that did not stop rashida
talib from tweeting
so long as he doesn't suppress my first
amendment rights to speak out against
netanyahu's racist and inhumane policies
the palestinian people deserve equality
and justice i wonder why she would tweet
that about tony blinken
i i can't i can't imagine why why should
we tweet that about tony blank by the
way susan rice endorsed tony blinken
so it that the team is back together
gang so if you enjoyed the team
get ready for more of the team and we're
going to go back to the way that
politics used to run in washington dc
was which is super exciting as well it's
not just that the old team is back
it's that we're going to get the same
sort of corporatism the dominated
washington dc
for a while there so one of the great
lies about america's corporations that
america's corporations are free market
loving entities that is not right
corporations are profit seeking that is
not the same thing as free market loving
there are many corporations that will
take government subsidies there are many
corporations
that in fact seek regulatory control
they engage in what's called regulatory
capture where they help
write the rules along with their buddies
inside the government well now gm
is demonstrating that it is ready to
play ball with the biden
administration gm according to reuters
said on monday it was reversing course
and will no longer back the trump
administration's efforts to bar
california from setting its own
emissions rules in an ongoing court
fight
gm chief executive mary barra said in a
letter to environmental groups it was
quote immediately withdrawing from the
preemptive
the preemption litigation and inviting
other lawmaker automakers to join us
but it's almost as though they are
attempting to get a pat on the head from
joe biden and company
yes corporations seeking special
benefits from the federal government
if you enjoyed that when obama was
president then you get it again
so much fun the dramatic rejection of
trump came as gm sought to work with
president-elect
biden who's made boosting electric
vehicles a top priority
the detroit automaker has laid out an
ambitious strategy to boost ev sales
last week said it will increase spending
on evs and autonomous vehicles by 35
from previous disclosed plans the
announcement reflects corporate
america's move to engage quickly with
the incoming
democratic administration in october
gm had joined toyota fiat and other
automakers in backing the trump
administration because
california is trying to set its own
statewide fuel efficiency rules
and zero emissions requirements the
trump administration said
hold up federal preemption applies here
we have federal laws that set the
emission standards you can't make
your own emission standards above and
beyond that the automakers are like yeah
that makes sense
presumably they want to compete in a
freer less regulated market now they see
the possibility of regulation coming
down the pike
and they're like we'll work with you
guys we'll work with you guys so it's
gonna be fun to watch the swamp
reconstituted that is that is excellent
stuff really really excellent okay
meanwhile kovid continues to wash across
the land and the hypocrisy of democrats
continues to be demonstrated full scale
so first of all let me just point out
here
that the media are garbage once more so
when it comes to covet
the media are just absolute horse crap
garbage
let me give you an example so cnn has a
piece today titled the number of coveted
19 cases reported each week in florida
has tripled since the state reopened
according to cnn
since governor ron desantis reopened
florida in late september the number of
reported coven 19 cases per week in the
state
has tripled on september 25th
desantis has signed an executive order
reopening the state freeing restaurants
and buyers who operate at 100 capacity
in the week leading up to the order
florida reported more than 17 000 new
cases
in the past seven days the state has
reported more than 53 000 meaning three
times more floridians have tested
positive in the past week
than in the week before the reopening
see florida's really really bad
according to
the geniuses over at cnn i mean truly
horrific
according to the geniuses over at cnn
there is only one problem with this
particular take
if you look at how other states in the
united states are doing and they didn't
do the reopening orders
you know what they're seeing guys you
know what they're seeing they are seeing
a sir jew would have known that no
that's a shocker i can't believe it
in fact let me read you the
the number of total cases
per 1 million population total cases per
1 million population
at current florida does not rank
it's just in terms of per 100 000
population how many new cases they have
not particularly high they're not
because they have a very very large
population also
new york totally shut down right new
york has seen a massive
increase in the number of diagnosed
cases week on week
i'll just take a random day october 8th
they had about 2 000 diagnosed cases in
new york
yesterday they had 6 000 diagnosed cases
in new york wait three times as many
cases in a single day as they had
just a month and a half ago why it's
almost as though covet is hitting
everybody and cnn is absolutely
and completely full of crap
no i can't believe it who would no
no that can't be the case again the the
bizarre
nature of the media covering this stuff
is that republicans are always bad and
democrats
are always good new york cases have
multiplied times five on a daily basis
since september right i just gave you an
october number it was even lower in
september
okay but don't worry democrats know what
to do they are setting new rules and
it's exciting stuff
so andrew cuomo the idiot governor of
new york who's presided over one of the
worst death permian rates in the nation
he said yesterday that officers must
must enforce covenant 19 laws in fact if
you don't enforce a covenant 19 law and
you're an officer and you refuse to do
it
you're a dictator so i think he doesn't
understand a language that we call
english
where dictators are people like i don't
know who who declare randomly
that we should completely shut down an
entire state's school district for no
apparent reason
that seems more dictatorial than an
officer saying i'm not going to enforce
mandates that seem to me to violate
individual liberties nonetheless
according to andrew cuomo it's the
officers who are the dictators
i believe that law enforcement officer
violates his or her constitutional duty
i don't consider them a law enforcement
officer
because you don't have the right to pick
laws that you think you will enforce
and you don't enforce laws that you
don't agree with
right that's not a law enforcement
officer
uh that's a dictator a dictator is the
person who decides he doesn't want to
enforce particular somebody should talk
to barack obama about the deferred
action for childhood arrivals program
i'm old enough to remember when that guy
declared that he could simply disregard
immigration law because he was a magical
magical man
and he could use his pen in his phone to
magically change law andrew cuomo might
want to talk to that guy about selective
enforcement of law
also the good news for andrew cuomo is
the rules don't apply to him so
he he announced actually on monday that
he would be spending thanksgiving with
his 89 year old mother
and his two daughters that was exciting
stuff here was yesterday
the story is my mom is gonna come up
and two of my uh girls is the current
plan but the plans change
um but that's my plan that was his plan
you see so he said you can't have
thanksgiving with your family you are
one of the common folk
no thanksgiving with your family but you
know who can have thanksgiving with his
89 year old mother and his two daughters
wait you know what i was told i was told
intergenerational dinners
that are filled with people eating
turkey in a closed room
that's a bad idea so he's got his 89
year old mom and his two daughters
who last i checked i believe are in
their 20s and they're all in the same
room together
and they're sharing dinner isn't that
nice he's having a thanksgiving guys we
can't begrudge him i mean he's been
working hard
at killing all the old folks in the
state he's been working super hard at
writing a book about how wonderful he is
while people die he
like he won an emmy we cannot begrudge
him his thanksgiving dinner
these standards do not apply to andrew
cuomo
okay so he now revised that later in the
day his office issued a statement
clarifying the plans have changed
his senior advisor rich as a party told
the wall street journal given the
current circumstances with covent cuomo
will have to work through thanksgiving
oh
that isn't that nice and then nice by
the way he said on sunday quote next
thanksgiving you'll ask yourself did i
do everything i could to keep my
community safe
the rules don't apply if you are a
special if you are a special the rules
simply do not apply to you
it's really exciting stuff that's that's
really really nice and that i mean
if you're andrew cuomo you just can do
whatever the hell you want it's pretty
great if you're one of the commoners
however you just get boned
if you're one of the commoners then they
can do whatever they want to you so if
you are an la restaurant owner then the
entire state of california can can be
shut down for you
but governor gavin newsom in california
that's you can still go to the french
laundry
for 20 000 dinner 400 bucks a plate 22
people there including the heads of the
california medical association
you can eat in close contact with no
masks but if you own a restaurant in l.a
county
you can lose your livelihood because
you're not one of the specials i mean
let's face it there are the specials and
the natso specials if you're an elected
democrat you're a member of the special
cadre
if you're not an elected democrat you
have no capacity to exercise your reason
and so the specials will decide for you
here was an la restaurant owner
yesterday saying uh these restrictions
are going to literally destroy us
the biggest toll is going to we're going
to lay off the people that we just
brought back
we're going to furlough them likely as
we downsize to the takeout only which
you know requires less kitchen
less from the house staff so it's this
influx is just
it's it's about to break us all okay so
we don't care about him though i mean
he's not he's a special guy i mean does
he look special to you i don't know if
he's special
i mean he's wearing a mask which means
he's better than like stupid republicans
but but he's
he's not special he owns a business we
know people who own businesses are not
special only people who are elected
in order to spend other people's money
and make crappy rules those people
are the specials uh i i also will say
that
many of these rules make no sense at all
obviously so pennsylvania has now banned
the sale of alcohol at bars and
restaurants ahead of thanksgiving
the administration of democratic
governor tom wolf announced monday
alcohol will be barred from being sold
at restaurants in bars in pennsylvania
from wednesday evening until
thanksgiving morning
an apparent edict intended to slow the
spread of the china-originated novel
coronaviruses according to dailywire.com
and amanda presta giacomo
reporting dr rachel levine the secretary
of health for the commonwealth of
pennsylvania
most famous for suggesting that nursing
homes were safe only to remove mommy
from a nursing home in the middle of the
pandemic early on
dr levine said on wednesday november
25th restaurants and bars are ordered to
suspend alcohol sales at 5 pm
until 8 a.m on thursday november 26th
well that's definitely going to stop
this thing
i mean it as we all know it is really
the alcohol sales that are doing it
covet does not apply so long as you're
it's a very prudish virus
it's both woke and prudish which is a
weird combo so it'll only
apparently hit you if you are a
republican or an orthodox jew
and also you can avoid it by not
drinking alcohol that's exciting stuff
so
i guess that mormons are gonna do okay
with covet is kind of the the
implication here
say that that's that's exciting stuff
there are also new mitigation measures
in pennsylvania including targeted
protections for businesses and
gatherings
orders already in place and those
announced today will be enforced law
enforcement and state agencies will be
stepping up enforcement efforts issuing
citations and fines
and possible regulatory actions for
repeat offenders
so that that is just excellent small
business transaction data collected by
software and business services
provider wompley show about one in five
businesses open in january have stopped
transacting entirely according to the
wall street journal last month
most of them have likely closed for good
but again the good news is that um you
know if you're special then probably you
can ignore
all of this and meanwhile i have to say
the the generalized perception that is
put forth on coveted policy
the generalized line on coveted policy
is so backwards
so larry hogan the governor of maryland
who is a republican governor
i think that he has done a fairly good
job as governor of maryland
but he said yesterday something
completely insane
he said that there is no constitutional
right to walk around without a mask
and that it's the equivalent of drunk
driving here was governor hogan
well it's it's sort of like saying i
have a constitutional right
to drive drunk i have a constitutional
right to not wear a seat belt
or to yell fire in a crowded movie
theater
or to not follow the speed limit which
part don't you understand
you wear the mask there's no
constitutional right to walk around
without a mask
so a couple of things it is not like
drunk driving if you're walking around
without a mask and you are not
symptomatic and you are not known to
have this thing
it's like driving around sober and now
if you get close to other people
and you breathe on them that is a
different thing but walking around
without a mask
there is in fact a constitutional right
to walk around without a mask
it is just that at all times in all
places there are public health
exceptions to constitutional rights this
happens all the time
right there is a right to freedom of
assembly for example right that is a
constitutional right to freedom of
assembly
but there can be time place and manner
regulations that prevent that from
becoming a public health threat for
example
do you suggest that there is no actual
right to walk around without a mask is
to suggest that
it's an argument that proves too much
it's to suggest the government has it
any time and for any reason the ability
to tell you to put on the masks so so
by that standard the standard that if
you are walking around and you have the
possibility of making anybody else sick
no matter how remote or no matter what
the disease
we can tell you to put on a mask full
time i i'm wondering how do you put that
genie back in the bottle
at what point do we all stop wearing the
masks now my presumption has been
that we're basically going to be wearing
masks in close quarters until the wide
adoption of the vaccine
presumably march and april and that's
okay we can go back to our regular lives
in march and april and before then we
can go back to quasi-normal by going to
work
socially distancing wearing masks in
close quarters with others but the the
baseline notion that the government has
the right under all circumstances to
tell you what to do with cloth on your
face
seems wild to me crazy to me especially
when they're not abiding by their own
rules
this is this has gone beyond the point
of reason especially with regard
to a virus that in certain areas is not
actually threatening
the healthcare capacity of the state the
healthcare capacity of florida which is
being ripped up and down
florida rhonda sands is a bad guy there
is not an overwhelming of the healthcare
system in florida i'm talking to doctors
every day who are working in ers there
is not an overwhelming of the healthcare
system i talked to an emergency room
nurse
just a couple of days ago she said it's
getting worse than it was a month ago
but it's not nearly what it was
you know during the summer when we had
this vast uptick in florida for example
nonetheless there's this basic idea that
is constantly being promoted by the
media and that is the government
is the problem is the solution to all
ills simply by
interpolating particular regulations
they can stop things
simply by ordering you to wear a mask
all problems will be solved and if you
refuse to comply with the ultimate power
of government
it's because you are stupid or because
you are bad or because you rely too much
in individual freedom well if you don't
rely enough on individual freedom
outside that is significantly more
of a problem alrighty we will be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boren
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are nick sheehan
and rebecca doyle the show is edited by
adam sci event
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020
the trump administration begins the
transition process
joe biden names john kerry the climate
czar
and hbo wants to trans your kids check
it out on the michael knowles show
you